you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
in the last video which was on the topic
of a brief history of the internet
i talked about how the future of the
internet was under threat by article 13
and a lot of people wanted to know more
about the new laws being proposed by the
eu
so here we are so what is article 13
it's part of the european copyright
directive that was passed in september
of 2018.
essentially it's designed to update
existing copyright laws in europe but as
you'll see
if it stays as written it will affect
the whole world
so let's look at how copyright works now
and how this will change
the way copyright works on the internet
today is as follows
currently fair use laws allow for the
use of copyrighted content
this includes use for criticism
educational use
research and news reporting if something
is uploaded illegally outside of fair
use
then it's up to the producers of the
copyrighted musical videos to go after
whoever's
legally uploading content
with article 13 the european version of
fair use is largely thrown out the
window
and even more devastating and this is
the important part
the responsibility of chasing up illegal
content will shift onto the major
platforms themselves
briefly put article 13 places
responsibility on websites such as
youtube
reddit instagram facebook and twitter to
make sure that copyrighted material
isn't illegally uploaded
if they're found to be hosting such
content they'll be slapped with a fine
for every instance of this happening
and this results in massive unintended
consequences
all websites that allow user uploaded
content aren't going to want to take the
risk of being sued under article 13.
they're going to only allow content that
they can be 100 sure
isn't going to result in them getting
sued the chances are
regular user uploaded content isn't
going to make the cut and only the
biggest companies will be guaranteed to
upload legally under article 13.
so i understand that copyright
protection is important but the way it
is stated in article 13
is very poorly defined an earlier
version of the law stated that there
should be a use of
quote proportionate content recognition
technologies end quote
this would be similar to youtube's
current ai copyright recognition and if
the law stayed that way that would be
okay
but in the new version of the proposal
that was passed in september
vested interests lobbied to make the
language increasingly vague
now it reads that companies have to
quote cooperate in good faith when
dealing with copyrighted content
the eu's definition of good faith could
mean anything
for example all content that could be
interpreted as copyrighted material
might not be used in good faith
this is just setting the system up prime
for abuse
every frame of video every drawing every
sound
every photo will be under heavy scrutiny
even simple things as small as logos are
all copyrighted material and they're not
going to be allowed
such a broad definition ends up making
the law potentially extremely strict
youtube ceo susan wojcicki stated that
article 13
quote poses a threat to creators
livelihoods and all of our ability to
upload videos to share our voices with
the world
the proposal could force platforms like
youtube to allow only content from a
small
large number of companies it will be too
risky for platforms to host content from
smaller original content creators
because the platforms will now be
directly liable for that content
end quote so here's more about what
youtube themselves had to say on the
topic
as currently written by the european
parliament article 13 could mean that
youtube is forced to
block millions of existing and new
videos in the eu
many types of videos could be blocked
those include educational videos
lots of official music videos fan music
covers and
mashups parodies and more
the proposed version would eliminate our
existing notice and take down system
this would make platforms like youtube
facebook instagram
soundcloud dailymotion reddit and
snapchat
liable at the moment of upload for any
copyright infringement and uploads from
users
creators and artists platforms including
youtube would be forced to
block the majority of uploads given the
uncertainty and complexity of copyright
ownership
it's clear that this is a bad idea but
what about those outside of europe
will they be affected the answer is
probably yes
film theory puts it best and when
different countries have different laws
companies usually cater to the least
common denominator rather than having
different policies for users in
different countries companies will just
usually target the strictest set of
rules and comply with those then apply
that set of rules to everybody
for a recent example of this earlier
this year you probably got a flood of
emails from facebook google reddit and
pretty much every website under the sun
notifying you hey we've updated our
privacy policy click that you accept it
well the fact that you got all these
emails around the same time
wasn't a coincidence all of these
companies were updating their privacy
policy to comply with gdpr
the general data protection regulation
passed in may by
you guessed it the european union these
sorts of privacy and copyright changes
affect all users
so article 13 might just be a case of
old people not knowing how the internet
works
or it could be a case of a staggering
amount of corruption either way
we all lose although article 13 has
already been passed the good news is
that the law's wording hasn't been
finalized so there's still a chance to
turn things around
and here's what you can do if you're in
europe contact your meps via twitter or
any other means and let them know what
they're actually voting for here
if you're outside of europe you can sign
a number of online petitions
to make your voice heard i'll leave some
links below
if you want more information you can
head over to saveyourinternet.edu
okay so that just about wraps up article
13 but there's some other things i
wanted to talk about
so for the second part of this video i
just wanted to clear the air
i usually avoid getting political as
it's usually not of any benefit
and i'm giving you an opportunity to
leave the video now if you don't want to
hear a discussion about the eu
okay so for those of you still watching
the following
is strictly for the purpose of
elaborating on what i said in the last
video i'm just responding to some of the
reactions i had
so in the last video i mentioned that
the eu has grown out of control while no
one seemed to notice
and a lot of people got really upset
about that i know it was strong wording
but there is some basis to that the eu
has definitely seen a major case of
scope creep
so the eu was established to stop a
future european war
and started off as the free trade of
coal and steel within europe in the
1950s
and then expanded to include free travel
in 1992.
so don't get me wrong i can see that
these intentions were originally great
ideas but after the lisbon treaty in
2007 we started to see a consolidation
of power
and now the organization is even calling
for an eu army
and we'll get to that in a second but
aside from this i've also noticed some
concerning rhetoric
i first noticed some of the strange
language regarding the need for more
power when i was following the greek
economic crisis in 2011 and came across
this clip
and that is the real problem colleagues
why there is such a problem in this
crisis
because member states are reluctant to
transfer
new sovereignty and powers to the
european union
and we all know that the only way out of
this crisis is a new transfer of powers
to the european union and to the
european institutions
this was in reference to the lack of
economic collaboration between member
states for the greek bailout and that's
definitely fair enough
but the language used here suggests that
the only solution is more eu power
not simply more discussion and
corporation and that stuck with me
and by the way according to insiders
like jim rickards who is the financial
intelligence analyst for the us
government and was consulted on the
issue
these economic problems in europe were
caused by a lack of consolidation of
debt by the eu member states during the
creation of the euro currency
so logically i can't see how more power
to the eu is the best and most efficient
way of solving this issue
it seems like an unnecessary bid for
power anyway back to the scope creep and
the eu army
in the previous video when i was saying
that the eu was out of control i was
going to play a clip of the leader of
the european union stating a need for
eu army if things go jean-claude
juncker's way
this will be the future of european
defense
in an interview the president of the eu
commission called for a european army
i ended up removing this clip from the
final edit because i felt that it
detracted from the main story
so the questions i have is what
populations of the eu member states
voted for such an army
it doesn't seem like a good sign full
disclaimer i'm definitely no expert in
this area but all i can do is logically
look at the situation
there are claims that the eu army will
reduce costs which i understand
but it seems to me that this will only
lead to more geopolitical escalation
there's even talk of this eu army
defending against china russia
and the united states a supposed ally
[Music]
what does this have to do with the
original goals of free trade and travel
within europe
and besides when has centralized power
ever led to anything good in history
statistically there's more risk of
things going wrong when you consolidate
power
just as an example if the decision
makers of the european union end up
majorly corrupted by monetary interests
which often happens but still has
unified military power
what then will we have yet another bully
on the world stage
so all of that thinking was contained in
a couple of sentences i said in the last
video
of course this is just an opinion and
i'm just looking at the situation
logically
you're most welcome to disagree and i
actually want to hear opposing sides of
you in the comments section
again free travel and trade is great and
so were other things like the encryption
protection laws
but i'm not so convinced on the growing
consolidation of power
oh and in the previous video i stated
that the leaders were unelected
and this definitely was an incorrect
statement there is definitely an
election process
what i meant by that was that the
correlation between the will of the
people in the eu member states
and the laws that they receive from the
eu seems to be weak so yeah using the
term unelected wasn't right
just wanted to set that one straight
anyway if you made it this far without
being mad
thank you you're a person of great
understanding i'm looking forward to
reading your comments on the posing
views
alright so that's it no more political
stuff and we'll get back to tech stuff
in the next video
thanks for watching and i'll catch you
again in the next video cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
you